the champions league final with the stad
de france was delayed by 36 minutes
because of problems outside the stadium
sky news forensic team has analyzed
available video to see how events
unfolded in paris
problems began shortly after 6 45 pm
local time more than two hours before
the game was due to start
a large proportion of the 20 000
liverpool fans with tickets were headed
for this underpass on the south west
side of the stadium
in this video we can see fans were
forced to walk through a narrow gap in
between these police vehicles
film from the other side of the
underpass this next video shows just how
many police fans had lined the street
making the flow of fans harder some
taking four hours to get to this ramp
just 100 meters away
sky news has spoken to fans in this
video who say non-ticket holders were
also joining the queues
the checkpoint at the start of the ramp
was the main one used by liverpool
ticket holders
at this point we've counted five
stewards checking tickets security were
wearing yellow vests and doing searches
space was tight and they were struggling
to process the large number of people
trying to get in
slightly later at the same place some
people were filmed jumping over the side
of the ramp to get to the concourse
past that checkpoint people were inside
the concourse but not through the ticket
barriers
the french interior minister says that
more than 2
600 fake tickets made it inside
at gateway there were large crowds
around the turnstile entrance
in this video from the same gate but
inside the stadium stewards and police
can be seen holding people back
paramedics are attending a man on the
floor
the ticket gates were closed by security
several times because of people trying
to force their way through
they opened this additional gate to help
but shortly after police used pepper
spray to disperse this crowd
in this video filmed at gate x you can
see adults and children moving away
this man is helping a young child remove
pepper spray from his eyes
on the other side of the stadium at gate
d stewards and security were overwhelmed
they tried to use bins to stop fans
breaking through
we counted at least 40 people getting in
other parts of the concourse people
scaled fences to get into the stadium
it's not clear if they had tickets but
fans who were there have told sky news
there were people trying to get in
without
whether it was industrial-scale ticket
fraud as france suggests is unknown what
the videos do show is that the stadium
staff were ill-prepared and
under-resourced to manage and process
the large numbers trying to attend the
game